all right so anybody in the livestream
world who's listening and watching this
this is a typical I don't know how
typical design review anyway we're
discussing new feature most language
which is integration of our system
modeler systems engineering system and
let's get going here so we're going to
look at the preliminary documentation
for what we're doing here um let's see
what was the name of the guide page I'm
supposed to look at system modeling
overview working oh here we go um so
we're running for those who are watching
and care we are running a preliminary
test version that has this new materials
in it okay let's take a look here all
right so let's let's start off so I
can't remember where we got to last time
but I think let's just enter some basic
thing here we've got here like this all
bigger we've got here a system model so
what do I do what happens if I press +
here you'll see it a little bit bigger
diagram older model this is a full-size
diagram normally dos are fullscreen you
know when you use the full system
modeling tool those are full graphical
diagram based modeling here it shows you
that diagram but you don't want that in
a list if you've got many of them so it
has an abbreviated form why are we using
I mean we're still sticking in these
diagrams with a pure blue even though
we've gone we've color as significant
color significance domain blue is
electrical domain okay so the outer
boundary of this image is also blue is
that yeah we don't know we can change it
but we should pick our I mean maybe we
should have orange like a standard
graphic or what is this no no it's
absolutely should not be stenographic
that's important okay well so what is
the model what was the kind of theme for
the system model of stuff um let me try
another domain can I try a different
domain how do I go if I do system model
not system model examples what will I
see here if I just say system model
examples you can become empty bracketing
will give you this choice I'm what
happening right now is it live it
loading something it's it's creating
this possible interface right so so in
the initial period there it wasn't
showing any kind of loading indicator
and probably should yes it probably
should and also we you're going to be
part of the loading indicator
standardization effort right
I'd like to you're supposed to be I'm
not sure who's coordinating that um like
they would surely know who is peering
that um okay so here
what is this this looks awfully big
right Donald sighs the colors yeah it's
honor and 25 percent but the colors are
not final this is a broken mess of the
system these are usually colored that's
okay so what is this so this is like an
inverted pendulum so what happens if i
press enter the pendulum forget that
what happens if I copy paste this
doesn't work otherwise there is a copy
paste button the top right one of the
three buttons yeah so I don't think that
that I mean we have a somewhat standard
copy paste button
okay that's what I guess in the end what
why not just have that string actually I
just changed that today and you would
get system model of that okay okay
alright so let's try so let's say I get
system model and now what happens so
this then if I press that I'll get this
thing cool this is nicely shrink-wrapped
whereas this is not but that's okay so
now if I want to simulate this what do i
do i do i say system model simulate yes
system it's just just a model plot of
that will that work
yes try in there works yet another
diverse no no no it's two different
things
system model plot gives you a plot
directly while sister model simulate
gives you an actual object with data you
know i was complaining about me about
the loading indicator that train yes yes
on the other one I'm adding the the
start of the functionality models on the
packed let download indicator those are
the only noise why are the why the
graphics the size they are I mean I
don't check to this I think this looks
pretty good but this is of the
preliminary way to do grids and it's
gonna look better once we get support
for for paneled plots --n okay alright
so let's try just so i understand if i
want to extract let's say i want to
change the parameters of this pen let's
say i actually just want that plot to be
to extend for more time periods how
would I start to do that then you how to
run system model simulates with an
actual simulation time so system model
simulate of your model
or plot okay Nona waterfront no I sure
this graphic by this point yes so you
want the actual data right and simulate
yeah simulate that and then there a
single time variable yes either a list
of start and time were just the end time
so you can say like 30 and then he gets
from 0 to 30 from what units if the
thing had units would those units be
included there it's the if the thing has
units it's gonna convert it to seconds
and use that okay if I just give a raw
number it will convert to seconds yes so
where I could give seconds here so if I
would say control equals 25 seconds for
example then that would do something
useful yes it would simulate between 0
and 25 seconds cool
okay so when it says model inverted
pendulum there that that model actually
has more this there's more detail for
the name of that model which is not
being shown that right so this system
model simulation data object has
properties one of those properties is
model name which will give you the full
name okay do you not want to have some
UI here that you can click on to get the
full name in this case maybe I think
that I don't think it's you think it
will be something directed by that most
to a time yeah summary name yeah I think
that's gonna be most of the time and
otherwise you can ask for it I don't
think it's gonna be good problem so
let's say I want to get an interpolating
function out okay is this plot what that
that wiggle there is that because that
come from one of the variables here yes
it automatically tries to choose an
interesting variable to create a minimal
diagram there okay and so so that's a
lot of variables 7:24 is that the total
number of variables required in the
internal so how do I get so if I if I
get system model there and I want the
equations can I get the equation so
let's go just to properties here
actually if I say property Association
will it give me the whole ball of wax
actually no you can do Association but I
will recommend it because probably a
property Association I think is the way
that you should do that because that's a
general thing that we've done elsewhere
and those have an association which
gives you that but it's gonna be slow
for large models okay
okay we go through these and these names
not all of them what our local
components and local plot names and
local plots so the models can be are
hierarchical and can use object-oriented
extents like what do you call it
when when you inherit something so you
have base models and then you inherit
stuff from that motor self model or
right as if they're local
I mean local seems like something
different when we've got clouds and
local and things like that right I mean
the names their property names can be
discussed but there is local components
and components or components flattens
everything out
actually yeah component component yeah
right yes okay
so I don't think local is the right name
I mean maybe itself maybe it's some okay
so as a controller gear remote for a
pendulum
right this is a slightly odd old
building and you newest build the
left-hand side of this element would be
strings and the right-hand side would be
new system model objects
you
but what what system model object what
where you see here the lq control system
for example would be a system model of
that thing that's is that makes sense
yeah i mix meant to it what and the
left-hand side string is just the name
of the thing in this local model yes in
the like sexy i don't really like the
word local rotor can you think of a
different word what do you mean by local
melted do you mean like that loan
instead of developed just for this
example no I mean here the called if I
think all five are local components it
means they're declared exactly in this
model while if you build on partial
models you can inherit stuff in into the
model and optics Larian locally so then
the local components are once declared
exactly here in the inverted pendulum
model well if you inherit something else
which has additional components those
are the inherited components and the
components are the union of those two
hmm yeah so this is the ones I mean you
could call the model components it's a
little weird
their other name I mean they're all that
it's not what a model name is model name
the name of the of the complete all the
name is just a string you have their
introductory examples systems in North
Carolinian pendulum
I wouldn't call that model name because
when we usually when we use name it's a
human-readable name
I think I mean that if it is a name um
waking calling model identifier that
seems better to me um what do we call it
in the case of an entity um the string
that represents that is the internal
piece of an entity I don't think we have
the right people hit on for that
question
unless you know I mean I don't have it
no I don't know
okay well the clarity antedates the type
that's more than I know their job is the
first element I mean they actually look
wrecking the element to the entity
I mean it's usually called the standard
name and it's that's the you know if I
say standard and I wonder if we even
have that I don't even know if we have
if I say oops what just happened my oops
that's a problem my keyboard is not
working
humph that's very odd I'm something new
and different um great okay
exciting um you see
I just felt Lilia today but why did it
fail again
try plugging and unplugging it again
you
that's working again very odd okay um we
have the canonical name of of the
entities that's what it's called
canonical name
I think the five-day canonical name and
why see for example
then I will say no there we go so this
is probably closer to canonical name
right right yeah yeah it's it's very
like economic only and that it's a
unique identifier for this specific
thing
but now the system model it but but
users if different users will create
those Stephen so you understand
that those will be users okay I think
I'm not territory sir
look let's make sure we cover what you
wanted to cover in this meeting cuz I'm
just poking at things randomly here
right what did you want cover oh right
so maybe we should go through the things
we haven't covered before one is let's
see if you go to college evaluation okay
go ahead go ahead if you go to mobile
simulation a topic add page link there
we've covered some of those one other
than there is one new symbol Daan's last
time system model progress reporting
it's an option it's an option for
controlling how progress reporting
happens
so even here's another place where we
can generalize to have a generic right
now there is something called net train
progress reporting okay yeah I think it
could become a general progress
reporting thing that we start supporting
when a fella vote for me yeah
I mean what other places do we have and
we also have don't we have a reason
there might be some unique things but
then you have to dock you know in other
words this is a general symbol progress
reporting but the old functions may
support the same kinds of things there
might be sort of restrictions and
extensions that's the problem
I understand but um okay well hold on a
second so step monitor is something very
much like this right except it's no it's
yes you have to tell it go ahead and
print something where's what this is
doing is this is proposing to do it all
so magically so to speak rather than to
require you to actually have an explicit
piece of code in there yeah right yep so
we can imagine any function say a pep
step monitor was sort of the first
generation of this if you like you know
where we provided such a mechanism right
well I think this is perfect sensible
but then I think we should be looking at
what functions have step monitor for
example um and there are nice way to do
that using wolfing language data um
I remember how to do this but um there's
a let's see
well look we can clearly find this which
functions have step water but anything
with a step monitor is a candidate to
get a progress I mean so you're
proposing I think that the progress
reporting arrow and then potentially
what we can do there is have a few
standard things that are very generic
but then some are gonna want to go
further like net train might want to go
further they have some other special
things that only probably applies to
that train I think there's no training
progress reporting Oh training progress
reporting yeah training progress
reporting okay so you you've copied this
basic scheme here I don't support the
function part why
it's harder and not not as obviously
useful at the first girl I mean but what
it's doing in general I would think the
function is being applied to an
association
okay I think they're concepts here like
patches may not make sense for everybody
you know it's only when you have batches
and rounds may not make sense but maybe
yeah etc well I assume that this is
using the unit's framework I mean so
that's just it the I see so there's a
unit here one could imagine something
which is I don't know some geo function
where it's you know doing some physical
you know what where it's looking some
number of kilometers around some point
or something whether units here could be
but that's getting a little bit picky I
mean you know to me it will be better
reporting and this one talks about time
into this talks about when not wear
serum Jane yes but what do you want to
talk about for system model progress
reporting is it also time or not yeah
it's we only need buy time talk
basically I mean it could also be you
could imagine a situation in which it's
simulation in which there are many
components in a system and you're
reporting which component you're looking
at the updating or something like that I
don't think that's gonna be useful the
way this is structured in the way right
now no but you might want simulation
time or real time might want to update
every two seconds yes or you might want
it every time it goes one second
simulation time
or you might want to update in a more
exotic case with a pendulum you might
want to update it every swing of the
pendulum
which is more oil that's more difficult
yeah but I mean if they're a natural
time you know time constant and a bunch
of the models
No No
that's okay so look just for this let's
just think about this for a second so I
mean progress reporting is first thing
is you know that they're very different
aspects of this there's the how how to
report ie
panel print etc you know you could
imagine a situation where you wanted to
send you a text message I mean if it's a
slow you know reporting thing um so how
to report then the next issue is what to
report
which probably overlooks I guess
alright kid partially yeah I mean there
could be a lot of choices and then
there's when to report
um so here let me just save this
someplace um
am i saving these do I have a system
model I'll be folders
system uh layup
okay great
[Music]
you
okay all right so then
now this is analogous to if you look at
document generator it has all kinds of
notification options right actually it
has a general thing called a
notification function
okay so that which has a function
applied to a certain um no no that's
that's true percent from background
tasks
okay so that's a model a partial model
in the sense that what is going to
happen so the what to report might be
apply I mean so one way to think about
it is this thing here the how to report
part let me make these um how to report
is basically function to apply to some
structure because that would be a
function that says
maybe panel doesn't work quite like that
but what the report would have an
association I mean panel might appear a
special case where you we provide the
function that's applied oh yeah but but
it's a little bit of a weird Phi mean
but yes that's right but I would say
that um you know what I let's break this
into how to deliver the report and how
to format the report
what's a report when to report um
so I mean to me this is beginning to
look like
supporting goes to and then it ends up
being an association that I mean it
might be that you can have a default
that just says panel or something but in
general the delivery method or something
or delivery function might be something
here followed by formatting floor mat
by
well is it interval I think that's what
we were calling it elsewhere reporting
interval or something
um
and then we've also got this notion of
what to report so contents maybe maybe
at the contents which would be a
potentially a list of string quantities
that are capable of being reported on so
to speak
see how those maps onto what we have for
training what is it called training
progress reporting yes
you
okay oh I see that's just a showing a
progress indicator
that's slightly complicated thing
because that will just be something that
has to know you know what does 100% mean
look I think we should have a separate
meeting to discuss these progress
indicators and try think so too I think
this is the basic direction that I think
we should be going in
um it's some kind of association with
attributes of the thing but it needs to
make sure that it is merged properly
with the way that some these
notification functions work for things
like document generators and can you
take that Stevens because I think you
you need to trigger it yeah okay fine
I will um and so then we fork that off
and and you know here is another place
where it's right for it okay okay
oh I'm just on email here um
okay let's go back to your agenda here
okay
then I'd suggest we look at how we
handle equations oh yeah and the four
variables of equations okay right so
let's look at the equations for this guy
here the police very complicated
right yes Valletta let me look here so
if I go here how do I get the equations
it's a system equations property
you
and it's gonna take forever to for
matter how complicated are they how
complicated can inverted pendulum be
there were 700 equations so pendulum
roller and stuff and there is also some
support for animation display of this
why does that have to be in there quite
okay first question what are these
errors
these are the equation translation
support is not a hundred percent yet so
there are constructs in this model that
we can translate into you or from
language shape ampersand right so you're
running a slightly old version of this
so that's not gonna be there in there
and yes all right okay
so one of the questions here so these
four variables which I'm not a big fan
of now we had a separate so what you
know so one thing Steven that makes
these equations become bigger is to
support flexible modeling that means
that if you connect two components you
basically get simple equations that says
a equals B you know the wires that
connect them so there are trivial
equations some of those can be
eliminated but then you then you won't
know what those variables are if you
need to know their value for instance
for analysis purposes I see so in other
words in other words there is a wire
which has one end is an A and the other
end is a B and so the presence of a wire
means that there is an equation a equals
B yes you can eliminate the wire
equation but then you don't actually
know what the then there is no variable
that represents what's on the wire right
that's correct
so simulation does that and it sort of
book keeps those things it knows how to
reproduce them so it does eliminate them
but then you know the bookkeeping so you
won't loose anything to your I'm saying
but if you actually want equations and
analyze equations you need to deal with
them all okay so hold on a second so so
what you're saying is when you say
they're 729 equations for the inverted
pendulum that includes these wire
equations basically yes lagus the
equations yeah yeah and so how many
would that be roughly in this case if
you didn't include the wire consistency
equations hello let me check but I think
it's it's stress it drastically reduces
it how much because because how much
you're asking is you know maybe there's
a property I assume these properties are
computed on demand these properties are
not pre computed is that true right yes
so then are you asking we need two
properties
one that is the full system equations
and one of which is the eliminated
system equations we actually have that
if you after the system equations at a
coma method goes to elimination as a
string goes to all think that's it
you
still getting pretty big something what
something's taking a while here so give
me a sense I mean some of these are the
models that we have that are you know
the higher-end models are we looking at
hundreds of thousands of equations yeah
in the worst case yeah so they went on
three hundred okay
from 729 to 180 yes what is it nervous
test discrete changes it's an internal
when I went and this whole thing we need
for a certain construct okay so how
would I get a more global sensor what's
here
I mean first of all these names are
incredibly long can I get these
equations summarized in some way um not
really how would I change every one of
those things into I mean if I just
wanted the skeleton of these equations
so how would I change is there a
substitution I can make that just
changes every one of these boxed objects
into something what's the head of those
box objects that's one of the parts that
we have actually changed in the news
builds those are quantity variables
okay what are these right here just not
name and then comma separated strings or
come arguments one each part of if I
just said here on line 16 I said and
then I say dot name of triple blank goes
to and then let's just say I'm just
going to make up something let's say um
I don't know green or something it's
just going to be a blob right that's how
those equations going to know you know
what I'm gonna have to put any unique
variable I'll tie um
that's fine or that well let's just try
it let's just try making those all into
green blobs and it's probably undo
something pretty stupid
a sense of what the shape of this
creature is well actually doesn't give
as much sense at all how can we get a
sense is there's some graphic
visualization we'll just show us roughly
what's going on with all these equations
I mean probably it will help if I just
make those into a column for example yes
if I pull if I do a multi column
I know how this works but multi-column
there let's just use our um okay that's
the number of columns so let's say if I
do four columns for example come on why
is it taking forever what is it doing
okay this is pretty hard to understand
yeah I mean so all the equations were
became green eco screens oh no I
understand that
so that will fail but I mean these these
things here are still you know this is
deeply in comprehensible what's going on
here
so what maybe you had a question about
these equations and my question would be
how do we illustrate you know how do we
give some kind of summary of these
equations or is that just not possible I
mean it's the summary of the equations
basically the picture of the components
right I mean an easier way to get the
sounds of a model is to explore the
components rather than going directly
for the equations I think I think
equations are very powerful you know so
that's the foundation of Amma delica and
system modeler but but they're super
large-scale systems of equations but
you're going to be saying equations of
the assembly code of modeling yes
yes absolutely actually fine that's very
funny that's exactly what we used to say
in home several people that have
designed higher end modeling language
state they view equations as assembly at
this scale when you sum up all the
equations for a model okay nobody wants
to look at assembly code so we just
shouldn't worry about it so what's your
question about the equations no I just
wanted to point out that we have solved
this same thing and replaced them with
the use of quantity variable
murgatroyd basically the result of this
all named objects meeting series we had
we realized what those look like do you
want to show your screen and show me
okay
um okay go ahead
um so let me yeah so I chose us like
this in simpler circuit an electrical
one so this is electrical in electrical
circuits the basic point is we're
finishing the those things with the
cleaning mouse over one quantity
variable electric current yeah so that
the name is that weird string with dots
than that
yes so if you look at yeah if you look
at the input form here you see that it's
quantity variable to the string with
dots in it pretty nice that seems
perfectly reasonable questions about
that about the display up there do we
actually want to use dots like periods
like that or do we want to do something
more stylized I don't have a strong
opinion the dhatus has the thing going
for it that it's it maps into a pipe
pipe yeah all right okay I mean this is
pretty ugly stuff but but I guess that's
life okay yeah we said the way you don't
usually look at the equations in this
right at this scale okay if I look at
Galatians you look at them for a
specific component usually yeah a small
scale equations are great at large scale
I mean there are two but you need power
tools which yeah right okay so let's
keep going but it looks good so should
we look at what does parametric function
that was the thing we've discussed
before right parametric function
parametric and dissolve generates
parametric function which means that you
cannot regenerate quickly a solution you
can differentiate with respect to the
parameters sort of differentially what's
called sensitivity when you
differentiate the differential equation
solution with respect to parameters that
makes it makes it super efficient
yeah so let's try this for example let's
say we've got the system model here
thing of the inverted pendulum okay and
now we say I want to make a parametric
what just happened here - what just
happened it crashed okay um as some
older dynamic stuff and uh expand
collapse is not not fully final unstable
yet okay so when I in order to figure
out that parametric whatever it was okay
um no models are available to browse if
you really write it will come up again
okay loaded the system modeling
functionality and it doesn't do that um
startup
okay all right so so let's sum ah okay
let me just close these up
um I think these were Wow didn't take a
long time I don't say my keyboards oh
there we go okay so now what I was
trying to do with some parametric
version of this okay so I'm going to put
that down that system model there okay I
can unwrap it by the way do you have the
predictive interface doing sensible
things with these not yet we want to
have the final design first so you get
the right one and what do you do it also
complete for things like the the innards
of a system model there is already or
maybe not in your build but in in my
bill there is autocomplete for many
cases and all the possible places okay
fine so we had that already before we
just want to make sure that it's filled
up every place yeah we can have it more
places now great okay so let's take a
look here um okay so you I was going to
try a parametric version of this and I
won't talk about creates just a model
and so on and I know what what if system
model relied the look they do that's a
nice thing where you can get reliability
information about a model if you have
encoded such inference reliable doesn't
mean time between failure reliability
others what was model wrong no it
doesn't mean time between failure the
statistics distribution measure cool yep
if what if you put empty the rest for
individual components yes yes put some
you have to add on a per component base
it reliability information which is sort
of natural right because if you have two
different pumps with different
reliabilities you need to provide
different reliability information as to
base when they build up a big system you
synthesize all these things and the
reliability depends on how the system is
put together you know Candice fail the
system still work
I don't get very much has been going
there is a system that system model
let's see system model parametric
simulates which is a function
I understand but system model parametric
simulate has to have a bunch of
parameters right yes I just run it maybe
look at page no it needs some notes that
by the way is building lame well it
doesn't have its syntax stuff in it it
should have a red carrot at the end
there yes I said um she can look at its
page I'm trying but I mean in the source
you
okay so it's for a lot of stuff here
with variable V with parameters P yes
it's like there so the variable V is
what what variable they actually want
out afterwards so this is slightly more
restrictive than the system model
simulate you actually have to choose
which parameters you want to know it's
not supposed to be an hour just to nd
solve where you're giving the dependent
variable first it's analogous to the
parametric and ease off where you give
the the last and variable parametric and
dissolve is like nd soul but it has a
list of parameters last you can say you
know these are parameters should keep
track of these are you know some
constraints on them
okay so you recognize the beginnings is
it's just like in dissolve and then
their parameters lion um
okay so that those are the parameter
so you've given you a zoom interval
there so in principle with that a you
get that parametric function is an
infinite collection of interpolating
functions yeah I understand but my
question is why in terms of argument
order why is there no time variable in
parametric it's optional because it's
that information can be stored in the
model you can still give it if you look
at the last two usage so those ones
would give it between VARs and the piece
of I between the V sub I and the P sub I
you can insert a time that correct yes
yes that is correct
good little funky isn't it it's the same
primary no I know it's the same order
it's just the way that's dropping an
argument is a little weird but I guess
okay all right so in this case if I were
to do this biometrics system simulate
and I would to say what's a variable
here what variable do I have - could I
ask here for variables system variables
the way that autocomplete should also
work yes the value yes God how many
system variable rather 700 something
how can they be fit what would boom it's
the same model as before but that's the
variables those those are variables okay
so if I say motor resistor dot n dot V
resistor is typically not super
interesting right I mean it might be
maybe it's a body caught body v
underscore 0 of 3 whatever that might
mean right
that's the
the velocity in the third dimension
okay so I would give that as the
variable and what's it for an example of
a parameter an example of a parameter
would be done deal let's see if it's an
interesting can I get it out from is it
in the same system variables list or is
it different so it has a parameter names
well how do I get the parameters out of
the model parameter names
you
you
okay so if I said
something like what is controller dot
see but let's just take motor EMS there
as improbably okay so when I give that
there as the next argument there is that
correction oh yes
you shouldn't require a list maybe it
works spit out the list I'll make sure
it works without a lists and a future
right it's probably you need strings
instead of these top names all the other
ones will read things in new bills ok
fine but but so ok fair enough
ok fine I get roughly what this is doing
okay
so let's look back at the the overview
here so what else do we need to write ok
create system model what is that now hmm
you can build system models from some
objects that are themselves natural
system models like state highways right
yeah state phase transfer functions but
you can also use differential equations
and you can yeah those are the things
that this one support and then there's a
connect components where you wire up
existing components create data system
model what is that it takes various
formal data and basically creates a
single generator model often what
operating model of some kind a black box
model some cars yeah yeah can we put a
neural net in there just put in that a
net chain or something like that or net
graph in there because that again as an
input output function for operating
function well maybe but baby but what we
can't do now but which we will do is to
be able to include Wolfram language
things inside of the model that can but
what you can do now is to feed it
Jim saying you still need environmental
models you might need a temperature
around something you might need road
conditions or something but if you want
Wolfram language statement in the middle
of a model we have to segment that off a
little bit because these things run very
fast and they need to actually work in
the same you know it generates code C++
code right so can we generate C++ code
or make it run on a slower track where
it can call back into Wolfram language
during this so there are several things
the first of all there might be a an
altitude or something right yeah and you
know that will be called once right
you're just end up there I mean not if
you're discussing an aeroplane but I
mean if you if you okay he's got a motor
that's working at you know it's on the
top of you know this one right now
Stephen works perfectly fine for sort of
passive data at times here is audio
interpolating functions things that are
like that if it needs to dynamically
execute it needs to sort of be called
from that C++ code alright which the
compiler will ultimately be the solution
to that exactly but but also you know
there's another notion called
synchronous where you basically in
real-time systems you don't sample every
system at the same rate and so there is
a sub system where you can control if
you want slower track you know like
that's how you design real-time systems
not everything runs on the metal in a
microcontroller at you know thousands of
Hertz many things only run you know ten
times a second I'm saying the higher
level you know in these autonomous cars
most things run is a much slower rate
then then the on the metal controllers
okay so what does that look like so your
point is my point is that I think that
there's multiple levels the things that
need to run at the low level model level
it needs to to kind of basically compile
all the way out and run at that speed on
the other we in a possession to out
two autonomous models and can we output
the stuff for a flight controller or
something
yeah these things these things do
generate code it has its runtime and
yeah people use it that way
to plug it into other systems so right
now that's a system model of capability
to be able to generate code is that
correct yes yes
and only send it you're welcome language
capability or not
not at this time I mean it it does sort
of but it's it's not it's not in their
sets that we're explaining here okay
fine but I'm still trying to understand
but I'm not a keen on the on the term
create system level because usually what
that means is when we use the word
create it means create something in the
world
I rather than create something locally
in the expression space so to speak
I mean it's depending on how I look at
it it does create something in the world
if you also have a create document does
oh well if you have the system model and
system model or a graphical environment
as well it will show up there as well
and you can save it to disk from there
look I mean so in other words and you
really share a memory space it's not you
know they they share they have a storage
system that they share
it's persistent storage
well that's the reason to call it that I
suppose
we have a save system model which allows
you to save it to disk
that's kind of funky why can't I just
use um you know put and it's an
expression isn't it
another immigration system no it's a
whole hierarchy of models it's not an
expression okay - hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on this is one of these
we've got to make it work in some
sensible way so you know part of the
rule is that um um let's see um
[Music]
you know part of the rule is that the
thing you see must be serializable and
output a ball so you know what we've
encountered that issue and a bunch of
places recently where it's pointing to
some weird Ward Java object or something
and we've agreed what has to happen in
that case is that there has to be well
okay so let's talk about what what
happens in this case if I if I take one
of these things save system model yes
you know so one thing let me just
explain one tangle here which is
important to understand hmm so using
libraries for a domain like say
electrical circuits or thermal systems
or magnetic systems that's great it's a
great time-saver it's you know you can
model at the right conceptual level but
when you save it you might want those
it's a little bit like subsetting fonts
in Adobe or something like that you
might not want the whole font you only
want the things that make this model run
well okay so it will do the correct
subsetting of fonts if you like you know
to subsetting your models
that's right pop mom yeah when you do
that that means you can work on its own
without you having the whole of no I
understand so it's on explaining the
dependencies it needs exactly
okay fine but that's not my point I mean
my point is that whatever you see here
if I were to save this notebook
okay so let's be clear about one thing
it might save the notebook and reopen
the notebook the notebook itself will
contain enough information to recover
the model true or not true
true
okay well not necessarily no what do you
mean
if you save the model you will get that
model if it uses other models those will
not be saved
okay let's talk about that that's the
same if you open any notebook that uses
right okay fair enough
turn Venus that happens and this is
actually a model the safe system model
is modeled on save notebook there is no
book whatever size notebook dude or
maybe it's not Melissa dude it's a
notebook type okay that's different I
mean that it's the same thing but that's
just saved in the file system I mean
this I don't know sound why there's a
save if small the right why not the same
system okay but what why is that not
just put of you know this system model
thing to a file
wasn't it just that why does it need its
own function ma'am if we wanted it to
have that we would have to implement a
special down value for put anyway
ah
um I understand that well why would we
have to do that I understand the thing
is an expression right there in your
input format it's not it's more of a
handle to something yeah I know but it
took globally understood handle yes yes
so so in terms of what we save it's
sufficient to save the handle correct
No why not I mean if you create
something you get a completely new
handle that only access something you
quit if you want okay that's what's not
gonna work okay so because the thing
okay so okay that's not going to work it
has to be the case that the thing you
have in this session is serializable
right so what you're saying is that is a
handle to a shared memory space between
the words and language process and a
system model our process is that correct
and system modeling or some kind yes
right so okay so what I'm saying is that
some ray so I mean we have this issue
with other in other places right in
audio and things like this that this is
a case
okay so the route Roger you get what the
issue is here I mean that the point is
it has to be the case that the thing
that is in the input form is
let me show you a completely horrendous
example that is about to get fixed okay
of a really bad case or something like
this
okay so if I say autocomplete of I don't
know random sample of word list comma 20
or something like this okay I will get
something completely horrendous look
look at this is absolutely horrifying
what happens here okay
see that okay so how is that going to
get fixed the answer is that's going to
get fixed by actually including that
this list in the auto completion
function so that upon serialization it
can be reconstructed
because I'm saying so this is fair as a
cash you know pointer when when the
thing is actually live just like you
will have essentially a cash pointer to
the shared memory space the shared
system model a memory space okay so you
don't want to do yeah go ahead
then if you want that the electric
circuit is not a free-standing thing it
also needs the hierarchy of introductory
examples and component based switch are
packages which contain the electric
circuit and also other stuff
so in that case you basically need to
have all of introductory examples in
every single wait no we don't no we
don't because we are it's just like if
you reference something in the data
repository for example you don't need to
import everything from the data
repository it has a canonical you know
reference it has a canonical you know
UUID URL whatever you want to call it
right you are those are independent of
each other
but what you're saying is if you create
no but there is an electric circuit if I
create an electric circuits it's
probably gonna be pretty freestanding
but if I create a package with some
electric circuits that builds on each
other then it doesn't make sense to say
one of them no I agree but but what I'm
saying is you will save everything that
is your construction and the things that
are part of the medaka standard library
and so on you don't have to resave
because those things are available
globally to everybody right
what I'm saying is discussed that it's
your custom build that isn't part of you
know the standard low available stuff is
and it's just like you don't need to go
down inside the Wilton language function
and save the internal code of that
function because it's available to
anybody yeah sure sure yeah yeah go
ahead
even the stuff you build yourself is
gonna be a whole hierarchical stuff at
some point thank you but where is that
so that hierarchy is represented right
now in something that can be turned into
a Wilson language expression but usually
doesn't live that way because it's
living inside the shared memory is that
correct right or actually multiple I
mean the whole hire different pieces of
the hierarchy can be turned into these
system models so for example the
electric circuit here you have that is
one sis system model but you can also
have introductory examples
component-based that's also valid system
model that's fine but what I'm saying is
there is okay so what you're saying is
the SAV system model thing will what
will it save it as what will it look
like how do I get it was there it as a
dot mo file which is ma dhalika code
plain text
Wow okay
we've got him a delicate string so if I
take this mr. model here yeah that's why
it's gonna be saved
okay so if I take that and I say of this
more delicate string right
okay so that's some kind of Medela Co
specification okay so what I'm saying is
that in that system model here if you
build your own system model then what
I'm asking for is that the Medora cos
string or something equivalent to it be
actually available in that system model
as something which were you to look at
the expression you would see that medela
cos string now you know in its
representation in in an actual running
session right that string just needs to
be a you know it's a it's a pointer to
that piece of shared memory
it does not string exists in the shared
memory so not as a spring it's a it's a
syntax tree basically abstract syntax
study okay well fine but then the what
has to happen is that were you to
actually ask for part such as this so I
don't exactly know what the word rated
ooh this is but but roughly what has to
happen is let's see how do we make an
indirect expression that works that way
so you get what I'm saying so that if
you were to look at system model if you
were to do an input form on it you would
basically see that that string because
if you can do that then all of the
saving stuff will just happen
automatically
the more delicate language has
additional restrictions of how you're
allowed to save stuff and mo files you
can't just put them in any mo file I
don't care it doesn't matter it doesn't
make any difference what I'm saying is
if system model the function contains
something where it is able to eat not
just these names right like
component-based electric circuit but
also mo delicous strings it clearly can
eat metallica strings because that's
what it's doing when you load from a
file right yes
so if one of its arguments effectively
or something in its structure is on the
delica string it should be able to
reconstitute that live Metallica
construct right mop not all of it I mean
if you only have this ring you couldn't
necessarily reconstruct your model
listen there are things there are
dependencies right some of those
dependencies around a standard library
those are underneath then there are
dependencies that are on things you've
built which you know you've got to have
otherwise obviously you can't
reconstruct it
yes but I'm saying it yeah those
dependencies if you put those in a
hierarchy which you're encouraged to do
for organizational reasons I mean it's
it's gonna be easier to find them all
right so most likely what you would end
up with is an association which says
this will be the you know this this is
the something like let's just imagine
majolica data arrow whatever and then
you know let's imagine the what's inside
system model is um you know model name
or something model I don't know
canonical name whatever whatever you
call it I don't know which is and that's
the whole that if there is just a single
name it's probably just that or it's or
instead it would be something like
um I'm making this up which I'm not
quite sure what the right way to do this
is but something like main arrow
whatever that's the that's the top-level
thing that is what this system model is
going to be together with are not
telling like keyboard Snowdon um system
model where together with the sub
dependencies whatever they're named so
what I'm saying each one of those is its
own Metallica string so it's as if you
had those separate files and making
sense
you're done okay this so in the example
for the electric circuit here you could
have
represent introductory examples the
package but how do you represent further
down
but look whatever you need to represent
you have a whole directory here you have
a whole hierarchy you can represent
whatever you need to represent you have
no delicate strings which would be
however these are represented normally
you are simply representing that
filesystem as an association just like
you do in the low filesystem app works
system map can give you the contents of
files in an association where the names
of the files are given by the keys in
the association so I'm suggesting doing
the same thing here and what's the
purpose of this the purpose of this is
that there you don't need all these
functions like save system model because
what you would have then is that simply
an export to model occur if that's what
you want of this system model but in all
cases what you end up having in the
system model object you know the system
of expression is a self-contained thing
I mean we can still have export to more
delica I guess without I understand but
but without this but but I'm saying that
but this is a principle that we need to
follow but whenever you have an
expression like like you could see that
example for the autocorrelation function
was totally stupid you understand that
that was stupid because if you save the
notebook you you know save the
expression you're dead meat you can't
reconstruct anything right right so we
want to avoid that I mean clearly there
are some cases where there's no choice
like a file pointer or something an open
file in a session where there's a random
file pointer pointing it in la-la-land
that's that doesn't work if it was a
pointer to something in the cloud
whether the UUID then it does work right
I need to disappear in a moment here um
but I can see if I can come up with the
way that works with Metallica I'm not
sure it's gonna be possible but well but
I mean is what I think we should we
should aim for it's something where what
you see in the system model is kind of a
[Music]
there's there's the additional
complication that if you modify
something in the graphical environment
it's that's not going to modify this
side
well we'll think about that let's think
about that look the right thing to do is
that system model is somehow lazy okay
and the
you're serializing to the point of
saying input form it's going to it's
going to resolve the laziness get what
I'm saying but it doesn't necessarily
have to resolve the laziness I mean
there plenty of colony calls variables
whose values do not resolve until you're
actually going to save them to go what
I'm saying
right and that's what I think should
happen here that is that the that the
thing should be you know you have a
system model it's got its name it's got
its picture etc etc that can be lazily
derived from the cut from the shared
memory
right up on to Elevation um it now the
question is what do you save in the
notebook in that case yeah exactly
if you realizes some input formats now
we're gonna well then worst cases is
invalidate I mean worst case is you say
what you can and it in it simply says
it's you know it's invalidate some thing
which in some civilized way just like it
would have to invalidate file pointer
right so in that case we will also
invalidate if you modify it in the
graphical interface probably probably
will invalidate updating it to the
nearest state at that point um I
unfortunately have to go so um we we can
continue this and for those who've been
watching with live stream stayed no know
what how does they said um next it's not
quite stay tuned we're not doing an ad
break where we're stopping here there'll
be another episode um where we find out
what happens with them the exciting life
and times of system model